- When you think of Wrigley,
the first thing that come to your mind
is the grass, the marquee out front,
and the scoreboard.
It's like one of the main
body parts of Wrigley field.
I'm Darryl Wilson.
I'm a scoreboard operator
for Chicago Cubs.
(jazzy music)
I've been working at
Wrigley field since 1987.
Wrigley field is one of the oldest
ballparks besides Boston.
It's been around for over a hundred years
and basically nothing has changed
on the scoreboard since 1938.
In the scoreboard, we
have at least three guys,
if we're lucky four.
While the Cubs game is going on
my job is to post scores inning by inning
and pitching changes
throughout the league.
(crowd cheering)
Once all the games
start and the scoreboard,
it's pretty chaotic.
You're writing scores
down on your clipboard
and you're changing scores while
you're also yelling at other guys
to change their scores in their games.
I can say though it's hot.
It's very noisy.
The walkways are a little narrow.
You got plates, numbers everywhere.
The switch out of the scoreboard plates
starts with a shift punch just
to pop it out of the slots.
The plates are made out
of a lighter thin metal.
You definitely have to latch
if you wanna make sure that they're locked
in, so that if the wind's blowing out
they won't blow out at you
or something like that.
You're running up and down
and changing scores for
eight different games.
I would say it's definitely hard work.
The view is outstanding.
It's just like a 360 degree view
of the entire ballpark
and the neighborhood.
It's like looking out to your backyard
and having a perfect lawn.
I mean, that's what it feel like.
You're walking out, you just feel proud.
You're just proud of your work
and the work that the guys put into it.
The reason why I believe
that the scoreboard
is special to fans, because it still
keeps that old luster of
the old time ballpark.
I've seen a lot of modern parks,
but Wrigley field has an
authentic original feel
of how baseball began.